can you do a video on why women leave
good men why it's mainly women who are
settled with a house kids and a good
husband decide to act
leave it all and act like teenagers
again go from their 40s to a teenager
so
it's a good point right there's um
there's several movies that have been
made for women you could call them
divorce porn where it's like basically
it encourages women to leave good
marriages to go be on their own and
chase their dream because the grass is
greener on the other side of the fence
and they legitimately think that they'll
do better
but what most of them find out and when
i say most i'm going to say
probably a good 80 percent of them
that the grass is not unless it's really
really bad but generally speaking for
most of them that leave good guys they
find the grass is not generally better
on the other side and they end up having
regret and remorse about it and it's why
we have such high levels of
antidepressants you know prescribed to
women over 40. i think the rate is
something like five times higher than
what men get scripted antidepressants
um alcoholism they love their they love
their wine nights with their girls
that's for sure
and then all they got to do is get those
like boxes printed where it's got like
eat
love
prey on it like with big handwriting and
they have that [ __ ] all over the wall
you guys have seen this stuff but
it's uh
it could be for a number of reasons one
of the things that pops up over and over
again is that
these chicks are getting married at like
20 23 something like that maybe too
young
they get their kids out of the way
they're 38 39 years old you know like 20
years later something like that kids are
pretty much out of the house or maybe
they got one or two left in the house
something like that
and they're
you know they just see their
their friends getting divorced and they
see all these
shows shown to them
sex in the city was a big one right
four middle-aged women that thought that
they were the cat's ass running around
new york city
sorry not running around slamming their
way around new york city um
you've seen it a hundred times and
there's nothing you know that you can do
about it women leave marriages eight out
of ten times so whenever there's a
divorce
it's the check leaving the dude
why do they do it because they can't
they're motivated contractually in
family law to benefit to break the union
if you married a a guy that's competent
and making money even if he's a dork if
he's a total beta if he's making two
hundred fifty three hundred thousand
five hundred thousand dollars a year
making bank
and she's not happy in the marriage and
she can take half his [ __ ]
and she's also paid handsomely monthly
and she's also got child support if
they've got kids together
very very well looked after women in
fact
you go to the gym and you see them there
during the day in their 40s and you know
they show up in a range rover they got
all the work done but they're old you
know like
guys don't look at them the same way
that they look at a chick that's 20
years younger they just don't there's
nothing
you're never going to get away from that
so
it's somewhat of a delusion some of them
do get upgrades you know some of them
leave like a total loser or maybe they
were the breadwinner and you know it
cost them some money to get out of the
marriage but for the most part
that's how it rolls um
it's it's uh
it's a fact a reality man that's
that's why when guys are like i would
like to get married okay well do you
know what can potentially happen if you
try to try to untie that knot why don't
you know before you go and decide like
oh i want to go get married why don't
you go sit in family court for an
afternoon just take an afternoon off you
know pack yourself a few snacks
go down to the family courtroom and just
sit at the back road just watch how guys
get treated through the system before
you go running out there you know
marching into the slaughterhouse with
your eyes closed at least march into it
you know with your eyes wide open and
move to a state that's friendlier to
fathers
i had a cast on at the start of the year
i can't remember which episode on
the unplugged alpha but go back to
january and there was a guy on that was
an expert on
defining which states are friendlier
towards fathers
texas arizona tennessee florida i think
tennessee was the top one where
basically it's default 50-50 but if
you're going to get married you need to
plan for stuff like that especially if
you live in the u.s i mean why would you
live in a state that's going to bend you
over and destroy your life when you can
probably
drive five hours away to another state
get probably get a lower tax rate more
freedoms and you know
a friendlier environment for dads you
get my point anyway let's grab the super
chat real quick friend of mine had a
girlfriend that tried to seduce me and
when i said no to her she told him that
i was trying to seduce her and the dude
tried to invade my house and kill me
with a knife
yeah well i'm sorry to hear that my
friend
but
women lie
hoes lie man three or fours just do that
it's not my fault thiago did it
that's not true and of course you know
the boyfriend will go chasing you down
um
optimizing the single man's life that
would be an interesting topic an
interesting detail i was dating her
sister
yeah
date her sister absolutely why not hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you